bitcoins price climbing up how are you
feeling market sentiment wise right now
as uh as it feels like there's chaos
across the world feels like bitcoin may
be the the signal and the noise what do
you think
yeah i mean i don't think too much has
changed uh since our last convo uh still
kind of a similar backdrop i mean
there's three things that i look at uh
like from a market standpoint there's
the macro which is the big driver right
now but from the bitcoin standpoint
there's the kind of the supply dynamics
which we can see with the on-chain stuff
and then there's the derivative stuff
which is kind of the speculate like the
speculation the leverage in the system
and so really you know from those two
fronts the the on-chain supply side
dynamics and the derivatives the the
markets look really really healthy and
so you know bullish for a long time it's
just this macro backdrop uncertainty and
the kind of liquidity tide of the legacy
system is really what's making the
difference right now
i i think that's a great way to kind of
frame it let's start with the charts you
have uh bitcoin balance on exchanges
just continues to fall off a cliff uh
what's your read on this obviously that
seems to be pretty bullish but how are
you viewing this
yeah um so i mean obviously a really
good trend to see from just uh from just
an adoption standpoint and you know that
but not your keys not your coins uh
concept has really taken hold i think a
lot of the a lot of the stuff that's
happened geopolitically uh in 2022 has
been a big advertisement for
self-sovereignty and and holding your
own money you know obviously uh not
everyone is a nation invading another
nation or
uh you know living living under a
dictatorship or or whatever where you
know you're at you're gonna have your
money seized but just the principles of
being able to control your own money is
something that doesn't really exist
uh within many other things or really at
all in the sense that you know the
bitcoins bitcoins network is completely
censorship resistant and so
this is a really good trend to see and i
kind of expect this to continue just
kind of chipping away at new lows i
think we're at uh almost four year lows
here absolutely and i think it only is
going to continue talk to me about the
bitcoin long-term holder relative supply
as you look at this
yeah so this is just uh we can kind of
see we can quantify long-term and
short-term holders uh and if we remove
the exchange balances from this metric
uh what we can see from the circulating
supply rather uh we can see relative as
a percentage long-term or short-term
hold or supply and so when we kind of
see exchange balances falling at the
same time as this long-term holder
supply is is kind of in this like supply
squeeze threshold right it's like near
that it's above 80
uh if i'm if i'm seeing it right here um
i should i should know this off the top
of my head but this is kind of at the
level where you start to see if there's
any really marginal like you know amount
of inflows into the market and obviously
at a higher market cap it takes more
more money to really move up the price
in a significant way but we're seeing
here is the circulating supply rather
that that free float supply that's
available to be purchased is just really
really low so when the inflows come back
into the market and this has kind of
been i've been repeating myself here for
a couple months and prices just been
ranging around but at the same time
under the surface the amount of bitcoin
that's able to be purchased you know the
hot the stackers the hodlers under the
surface continue to just buy and so you
know when the big wall street funds when
when anybody that doesn't have exposure
and is somehow sitting at zero wants to
come in and secure their slice well
they're gonna have to bid up the price
in a pretty big way hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time